[Musique]
le président de la Russie Vladimir
Poutine biais de quitter la scène où il
a passé plus de 4 heures à répondre aux
questions des journalistes sont exercice
qui est toujours important à la fin de
l'année cette conférence de presse
annuel de Monsieur pouce et demi et
aujourd'hui elle était encore plus je
voudrais
les tensions que génère les troupes qui
sont massés à la frontière de l'Ukraine
est cette menace constantes depuis 3
semaine 4 semaines déjà
en Ukraine et la question était posé il
y avait des centaine de journalistes ici
très clairement
pourquoi
nous on
veut
on veut
on veut tout de suite on les veux
maintenant
aujourd'hui
ici Tamara Alteresco Radio-Canada Moscou